so wait is it true um that uh so you and
scott y'all
added to your family during lockdown yes
we did do you want to see
this person yes because i have a golden
doodle
oh you do yes wait i don't want to see
he was he was just in here
come here come here oh my god oh my gosh
he's
huge he was supposed to be a miniature
hi
he wants to be a miniature but he's not
he's like 40 pounds
his name is henry
stop it oh my god
i woke him up and he's sleeping does he
have puppy breath
oh if puppy breath means horrible
horrible breath like mine then yes in
the morning yeah
no i it's so funny so how big is your
golden doodle gonna get is that a
miniature or normal like
normal it's normal um his parents are um
you know like um 50 to 60 pounds
well this one was supposed to be 15 to
18. lies and deception
um you're about 40. um but he is the
sweet golden doodles are so so
the reason why i went for it because we
have oh my god i used to hold him like a
baby
he's so cute yeah they're the best right
especially in quarantine because
he has to be super depressing and i only
have like
i it's not that bad i only have like
five nannies for him can you can you
can you come and see watch i just do
this can you just thank you so much
one feet hello one
one feeds one walks one naps with i love
your five nannies
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going